>>Roger Weissberg: I don't think
that children have advocates,
and my goal always has been
to do what can be done,
so that students are successful
in school, and in life,
so they feel good about
themselves, so they feel good
about where they live, and their
families, and they have a sense
of optimism and they feel that
they're going places in life,
and they matter to others, so that
is part of the passion that I feel,
doing things that can
improve the lives of children.
>>For a number of years, people have
said, "Oh, if we spend time focusing
on the social and emotional
side of things,
it might be at the
expense of academics."
But we've found something
entirely different
in the work that we've done.
We've found that if you focus
on the social and emotional,
it improves children's behavior,
and it also improves their
academic performance.
So this is a two-fer now,
if you address kids' social
and emotional growth, you'll also
be benefiting them academically.
And this translates in terms
of achievement test scores,
so that one of the
things that we're finding,
and we were really quite surprised
when we began this overall study,
is that children improve
11 percentile points.
In other words, with some of the
other studies that have been done,
that look at the impact of class
size, or other kinds of programs
that even try to promote
academic performance,
this increase of 11
percentile points is a big deal.
>>In Illinois, we have social
and emotional learning standards
that are part of the
Illinois Learning Standards.
These are things, now
social and emotional skills
that children are expected to know
and be able to do and the fact
that there is a policy environment
that is supportive for doing social
and emotional learning
instruction, commits teachers
to doing the work more effectively,
because they feel it's something
that is supported, and
encouraged by policy makers.
>>We talk about three Ps that
are going to be necessary
to make effective social and
emotional learning a reality.
One thing is policy, federal
policy and state policy.
A second thing are
principals in the building,
we find are extremely important to
make this work, and come together,
so for leadership, which
does not begin with a P,
but principals do, that's important.
It's also important, of
course, to have superintendants
and district people involved in
supporting this effort, and finally,
there's the professional development
and technical assistance
and support to teachers.
If we're going to do this work well,
there needs to be good guidance,
sound policy, and support, and an
investment in teachers doing this
in the most effective way.
That kind of support is going to lead
to students who are knowledgeable,
responsible, caring and ready to be
successful at school and in life.
>>It's one thing to collect the
information and to do the science,
and to see what the findings
are, it's another thing to think
about ways to share this
more publicly with educators,
with parents, with communities, with
policy makers, so that we can begin
to do what is the most
effective programming
that we can, on behalf of kids.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.